take a look at this picture and what do
you see a presenter of rapidly growing
fame helping publicize the plight of and
raise funds for children desperately in
need of help in some of the most
deprived areas of the world or a
self-styled white Savior engaging in an
act of colonialism and poverty porn
Stacey Dooley has found herself under
the most extraordinary and surely
misinformed attack from Labour's David
Lammy never one to miss the opportunity
to seize on any whiff of possible
offense proposing with the boy as she
raised funds for comic relief her crime
appeared to be she was white had it been
the charity co-founder Lenny Henry or
say Ian Wright everything presumably
would have been fine well there's an
observation for loony lamby and his ilk
fair-minded white people are allowed to
show compassion and want to tackle
inequality and if you don't like it mr.
Lambie why don't you go there yourself
oh that's right you were invited but
turned the opportunity down I feel like
I need to educate you now Nick please
about the white Saviour phenomenon
please even though we're calling it a
white Saviour narrative because that's
what it is there is a history of British
people going to the Dark Continent as
they used to call Africa and rescuing
savages by giving them charity while the
British state looted and pillaged their
economies by the way it continues to do
that today
well British people got to feel good
about helpfully rescuing these poor
children you know I've done quite a lot
of work on this and this actually
started during the Biafra war in Nigeria
when all these images of starving
children were suddenly beamed across the
world in newspapers on Fleet Street an
era when you were probably really
working in them and it's true there were
absolute atrocities happening in Biafra
in Nigeria children were dying but the
way the British press reported it had
absolutely zero context it was savage
tribes killing each other no mention of
the fact that this was a British colony
until a few years earlier no mention of
fact this was the oil-producing region
no mention the fact that Britain was are
arming one side in the conflict and
British people responded by trying to
adopt the African babies on mass take
them out so that they could give them a
better life in Europe wrong so to do
because that is not the solution
the solution is not to just take out
African babies away from these savages
who are killing them the reason they
were starving was because Britain was
complicit in a conflict that was
devastating just to bring it up to date
that's that narratives never been
challenged and it's never changed what
we have now is very well-meaning people
and by the way I haven't attacked states
of duty personally I think she does mean
very well I think everyone who takes
part in comic relief wants to help my
problem with comic relief is that it's a
massive distraction from the real issue
you know stay asleep when she responded
to David Lammy said this is about
African kids lives if you care about
Africans kids African kids lives then
know that the hundred and fifty billion
or so that goes to Africa in AIDS is
dwarfed by billions of pounds by the
amount we still extract from the
constant every year largely through
British companies who do not pay tax who
repatriate there are little children
like the one in that picture then why
don't you address well wrong that
continues to exploit and destroy their
of your ideas so lemme last week yeah I
thought his colonial imagery references
insulted they were hateful and insulting
to the people who given this country
they're talking about wife he talked
about white people like there were this
privileged bunch of people who were
throwing cup crumbs to oppress blacks
you insult every single person in this
country when you do that you know if
Langley stepped outside of the
Westminster bubble for narrative he
would see the profile of the people who
give to charity and it's not rich white
privilege people it's working-class
people it's your old your elder ladies
project
let me Karen you've had a long tour that
that's just right what can I can I just
can I just speak now because you you've
talked quite a lot on this he insults
people he'd sort someone because they're
white which is racist in itself he
insults
their their intentions for doing what
they're doing the idea that every white
person gives to charity to make
themselves feel good about themselves is
nonsense and it's hateful and it's
hurtful and if Lonnie keeps on talking
like this he will actually stop white
people from giving
would that make you happy any sentence
you're completely wrong Sammy was
invited to go buy comic relief and the
reason he said no this is a POS because
a blackface okay you've been a new pin
and yes I go every year to to Uganda
where I my wife and I support a range of
which is where the shot was taken of
yeah where that shot was taken well and
I we support a range of projects I
suspect that if the stasi put that up
herself not with comic relief and comic
relief wouldn't have put it up quite
like that but in the end of the day I've
seen the work that comic relief do in
places like Uganda and I think we should
applaud them well I think we therefore
should give and if you have you have
pictures like that which help raise
money
then I've got to tell you in the parts
of Uganda I go to they need money right
and the idea that the money can come
from the government it doesn't happen
right and the idea that you can do some
work that whether you need to publicize
it how you do it right that I think
that's a subtle difference but in the
end last year's comment relief or the
year before last I think I made 76
million and I think the advantages of
that diss out way the disadvantage as
you know I've been all over Africa
myself as well okay and I've seen a lot
of very money being abused you know I
mean people's paying far too much for
rent driving around in cars vehicle
parts are just stacked with stuff that
hasn't been used and money going which
isn't actually reaching its intended
target for me you know you can give your
money to charity and and you know you
can give to a charity or night and
anybody's trying to make a difference in
this world and do well it's doing good
in my opinion whether they do it over
they will do over here personally I
think we've got too many of our own
people sleeping in the gutters underfed
and living in poverty for me to give any
money to anybody all know that comic
relief would not get their money be used
in that fashion just to clarify its
being unfairly predicted because I think
you agree what comic relief or doing
you're just troubled by the pictures
that I used to work in development in
aid
African countries I've been in 20 or 30
African countries doing this kind of
work
there is nobody who's more committed to
trying to alleviate poverty on the
African continent than me my issue is
twofold one is with the idea that the
reason Africa's problems is because it
doesn't get enough charity and second
the way we do it so comic relief last
year said it wasn't going to put out
white Savior type images anymore that's
why I think you're right Gregg that they
wouldn't have put this out because they
understand that you need to be sensitive
to the fact that there is a history to
Africans being portrayed as passive
victim being glib had it been Lenny
Henry holding the little boy you're
relaxed about this this is this is this
is a way of showing people what is wrong
with the image of Africa that we're
portraying through these campaigns it's
very effective
[Music]
don't get surprised
[Music]
good
[Music]
[Music]
you've just seen radiator aid for Norway
because they're so freezing there and
Africans have so much abundance of water
that they should donate now if all you
knew about Norway with what you thought
in that video you would think it was a
very wretched place for the freezing
miserable people wouldn't she says she's
put this earlier she said David is the
issue with me being white genuine
question because if that's the case you
could always go over there and try to
raise awareness yourself and she's
absolutely Jesse his response yes I did
he said no it's not just because I would
be any different he made it sound like
this is not the babies and the starving
people in Africa give us stuff how the
money is raised or who was raising it as
long as they get food and clean water to
drink and their lives on let's get back
exactly it's good that's actually you
are drawn to your Tom to your point half
of the money that that can we believe is
now is spent in this country it's not in
the days when it all went to the third
board isn't it true in most of it in
this country but there is when you if
you go to the Uganda's are so I do every
year once you get outside of camp I'll
understand the poverty is still pretty
widespread and you do still need they do
still need support whether this is one
way of raising money is the truth and if
it could be that if if coming when they
don't do it in that particular way yeah
you wouldn't get the 70 or million
pounds and I think that's the choice you
take I'm just saying we should think
about the cost as well of doing it this
way